hi there today i am going to talk about
what is the easiest language to learn
because it's a question that comes up
all the time
and there i don't think there is a
simple answer because it depends on a
number of factors but i'm going to go
over what i consider to be
the factors that influence what makes
languages easy or difficult to learn
the first thing is to me
how many words in the new language are
similar to words that you already know
from your own language or from another
language all right
there's a thing called lexical distance
and you can google and you'll find a
number of sites that provide information
what this means is how close is the
vocabulary in language a to language b
all right so if you're an english
speaker
i use one of these websites to check
the closest language in terms of
vocabulary is friesian which is some
form of dutch but generally speaking
dutch and swedish are the closest to
english in vocabulary then comes german
then comes french and other
romance languages now i haven't looked
into all of this you know sufficiently
well but i would imagine that this
lexical difference
that people normally talk about refers
to the most commonly used words
because in english the most commonly
used words are going to be
more
the higher percentage of sort of
germanic type words go
come eat speak and so forth
uh when you get into more difficult
content you're reading on politics or
history or science then you get a higher
percentage of latin or in the case of
english french origin words so in
english for example 60 or so of the
vocabulary is actually a french origin
so
so again if we're talking lexical
distance here
theoretically swedish german is easier
uh closer but i i think if you are at a
higher level of your reading i suspect
that english is closer to french because
of the number of french import words
that come from the norman conquest
so that's one thing is the the sort of
lexical proximity if you're a spanish
speaker and you go to learn portuguese
basically you have 95 of the words uh
the same is true for
uh you know a swedish person learning
danish or a mandarin speaker learning
cantonese
uh once we move to the slavic languages
they're not quite so close in terms of
lexical proximity in other words
similarity of vocabulary
uh
you know russian is sort of the outlier
and languages like ukrainian polish
czech slovak
are closer
i don't know
i don't have information on the other
slavic languages this column the
southern slavic languages
so obviously that's one consideration is
how close the vocabulary is
uh the second consideration is
uh
structure so german may have a lot of
common vocabulary with english
but the word order is quite different so
swedish is actually a lot easier
to me i think than german
because it takes us a while even though
we understand theoretically that okay
the verb comes at the end but actually
to get the brain used to this uh
different structure i think is a bit of
an obstacle so similarity and structure
can be a help for example
as a person like me who speaks chinese
and japanese i have an advantage in
learning korean because 50 of the
vocabulary in korean is of chinese
origin and the structure at least the
word order is very similar to
japanese so these are all things that
influence what makes a language easy
but there are other factors for example
how much you know do you like the
language or even before that
what sort of
a learning content is available
uh because
it's important to have material that is
of interest to you and just a little bit
difficult to help you along until you
can actually start using authentic
material so very often it's the
availability of that sort of
intermediate range of learning content
having uh material where you have both
the audio and the text
so for example
uh i am learning greek now i would say
quicker than any language that i've
attempted to learn here i am i've
basically put five months into it and i
had a conversation the other day we're
talking about politics i can't say that
i'm fluent not by a long stretch but i'm
expressing myself much better than i was
able to do in korean after much more
effort or in check after much more
effort
uh and that is in the case of czech
after i had learned russian
and was speaking russian you know fairly
well and yet with with check i had all
kinds of trouble even though check is
written in the latin alphabet and that's
another consideration if you have to
confront a different writing system that
makes it more difficult it is always
easier for me to read in the alpha in
the latin alphabet than in the cyrillic
alphabet although i have read millions
of words in the cyrillic
alphabet
uh so but with check we didn't have a
lot of good content at link
and so it was always too much of a jump
almost to get me up to where i could
really take advantage of some of the
great material that the czech radio or
chesky roslas offered
the same with korean i didn't have
enough of that intermediate stuff and i
think that's where
the mini stories that i'm using for
greek have been so tremendous because in
fact greek should be more difficult for
me it has
it is much more remote in terms of
lexical proximity proximity vocabulary
to any of the languages that i have
learned it's written in a different
alphabet
it has a few
structural
problem column issues that i have to
learn but i'm learning it very quickly i
feel wow and i think it's the effect of
these many stories 60 of them which i
listened to repeatedly and that i was
able to get into and these many stories
use a lot of the day-to-day vocabulary
especially verbs which i think is very
important so to summarize here it's the
lexical proximity in other words how
similar is the vocabulary
uh and then to some extent the structure
uh
second of all it's the availability of a
comprehensible input in other words uh
meaningful things that you want to
listen to and read
in the language that's that is not too
difficult
for you uh because i think at the at the
upper end the truly difficult material
it's usually possible to find stuff
audio books newspapers newspapers are
easier actually but audiobooks with
ebooks and stuff like that these things
can often be found
but it's getting you up to that level
that's going to influence how easy or
difficult that language is to learn and
finally another important point in what
makes a language difficult or easy and
and and this relates also to a question
that i often get which is what is your
favorite language
the issue here of course is how much do
you like the language if you like the
language if you are motivated to learn
the language for whatever reason if you
don't resist the language you don't find
the language stupid because they say
things differently
uh you don't get frustrated because it
sounds like it's just one big mumble if
you have none of these negative feelings
about the language and you are very
positive and and motivated and you love
the language that's going to make it
easier
and i i was sort of reminded of this as
i was reading my
uh
greek podcast which i listened to and
then i read about greek history ancient
greek history and it talks about the
parthenon and it talks about athens and
it talked about the citizens in athens
and then the
metis meticos
who were basically foreigners who lived
in athens but didn't have the same
rights as citizens and then i said where
have i heard that before it seems to me
there was a song
called le metec by mustaqi
and so then i went to youtube
and i googled
le maytec by mustaqi i'm not going to
sing it because i'm not a very good
singer and i listened to it and i said
to myself you know i really love french
french was the first sort of new second
language that i really went after and
and became fluent in
and i think if i'm asked which language
do i prefer i would have to say
i love them all when i'm learning them i
love my greek i love my ukrainian
russian chinese korean i love them all
but my first love and probably still my
favorite language is french and i'm
gonna leave a link here
to uh
lumaytec by george mustacky and i
encourage you to listen to it and if you
fall in love with french then you'll
have an easier time
learning it thank you for listening bye
for now
[Music]
you